Desde la distancia grossbardorf puede
parecer un pueblo más de Alemania pero
si se mira de más cerca sus mil
habitantes obtienen casi toda su energía
de fuentes renovables locales la pieza
maestra una red interconectada de calor
y electricidad alimentada por maíz
estiércol y residuos vegetales
esas plantas fermentan mediante
bacterias producen metano ese metano
impulsa un generador para generar
electricidad como cualquier motor
necesita refrigeración Y esa agua de
refrigeración calienta el pueblo
grosor complementa esta red con cuatro
Molinos de viento y más de 8 hectáreas
de paneles solares El pueblo produce
ahora 15 veces la electricidad que
necesita con precios energéticos bajos
un gran atractivo
vienen empresas impuestos municipales y
sobre todo los jóvenes se encuentran
trabajo aquí y los jóvenes son el futuro
el modelo no puede aplicarse en todas
partes ni adoptarse de la noche a la
mañana Sin embargo puede proporcionar
independencia de los mercados
energéticos globales a las pequeñas
comunidades en un mundo inestable